we've had the idea that we couldn't mine
asteroids for over a hundred years right
late 1800s is when we first started
thinking about this in the first place
and today we have I think it's three or
four different asteroid mining companies
it's no longer an idea we actually have
companies that are actively pursuing
this and we also have really serious
economic reasons for pursuing this right
a lot of the metals rare earth metals
that we need to make all of our
electronic gear they're very scarce on
earth
totally plentiful in space gold platinum
platinum is a fantastic conductor
we don't build technology around it very
much because all the platinum on earth
would essentially fit into the back of a
flatbed truck right there's a very
limited supply it is everywhere in space
so there if you look at the history of
the world it's always been the search
for resources that has opened up new
frontiers it's been the economic driver
that has opened up new frontiers well
that economic driver is you know is
there in space
and you have to you have to think about
it this way if you go back 20 years ago
right when shell discovered the first
North Sea oil deposit it was beneath
5000 feet of water and ten thousand feet
of rock and they had to operate in this
very cold very hostile very far away
environment robotically to get at oil
this resource extraction North Sea oil
platforms are very very expensive but we
learned shell was willing to take a very
very expensive bet to operate
robotically in a very hostile distant
far and away environment to get at
resources right same budget sort of
applies to asteroid mining and it's the
same exact situation is a very far away
very remote robotically extracted
resource if we're mining asteroids so
we've done this before we've been down
this exact road and for the first time
in history we have the technology right
we've already there been three different
missions already to out of NASA and
out of Japan that have caught up to
asteroids we even won that Hayabusa
which is the Japanese probe scratched
the surface and brought back some dust
it's the low-grade first step mining
right so we already have proof of
concept we know it can be done we know
the resources are out there and there
are companies pursuing it will it happen
in the next 20 25 years next 10 years
next 20 or 25 or the next 50 years I
don't know if you talked to the people
running the companies they'll put a 10
to 20 year time horizon on it I think
it's a little farther out but again
we're gonna see it sometime in the next
50 years and you have to understand what
this means you know they did they did a
they did a study where they looked at
the amount of gold contained in just a
typical middle-of-the-road asteroid not
even like a metallic asteroid just a
typical middle the road one and it was
double what Fort Knox held at the height
of Fort Knox right so there's enough
gold in one asteroid to kind of devalue
every currency market on earth so that's
what's coming and it's really really
interesting right it sounds like this
crazy science fiction technology but
it's going to have real-world economic
impact on this planet within this
century and so we have to kind of be
prepared for it at the same time they
were thinking about it's still science
fiction
Oh